I think if you have four indictments and
all four of them look a little sketchy
to at least half of the country that
it's hard to imagine that this is
anything but political and if you look
at all the you know the surrounding
things that have led up to it from
everything from Russia collusion to the
the laptop hoax to the Fine people hoax
you see a pattern of really targeting
one person in a huge coordinated way and
I've said that what are the difference
between the the Democrats and the
Republicans this is just observational
is that both sides have a lot of BS you
know there's a lot of stuff that's not
true that people believe but generally
on the Republican side it seems to
Bubble Up from individuals so it'll be
somebody who has a claim and other
people latch onto it and then maybe
someday somebody leadership will say
that Clayton and then it becomes a thing
but on the Democrat side it appears that
they do organized
multi-organizational Ops you know the
the laptop the laptop was you know
Russian disinformation that involved a
number of entities that that wasn't a
few individuals there were people in
leadership who coordinated across the um
the government the Intel agencies and
the media and to me that looks like a
RICO case you know the American law that
would treat a criminal Enterprise as
operating in in some kind of coordinated
ongoing criminal fashion so that looks
really different
um and that's what it appears to be from
a voter's perspective who's you know
watching the whole field
and Scott one of the questions I'm
always curious to disentangle is when
you say it looks political are you
saying that Donald Trump is innocent of
all the things of which he's being
accused or not guilty at least or are
you saying that his behavior is akin to
Hillary Clinton's server let's say or
Joe Biden's documents or various other
things that are not prosecuted yet on
Donald Trump's case they will go after
every single little thing every time he
put a foot wrong so is it that he's not
guilty or is it that the prosecution is
actually persecution I guess is what I'm
asking well you know I think you get
lost in the details if you start
comparing you know the Hillary situation
to you know Trump or any other uh I
think it's a valid it's a valid
observation that they're not being
treated the same but I think you could
take it up a level and say it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if you did
those things it doesn't matter how bad
they were because the reason they're
going after doesn't seem to be related
to what he did and you you can make that
judgment based on how other people are
treated in other situations but if you
look at the you know as I said the
complex the entirety of it it appears
that there are ongoing organized Ops to
get rid of one person for reasons that
are not entirely clear but it must be
probably self-preservation or profit or
something but it doesn't look like we're
involved in anything that classically
would look like a democratic process it
looks like people in power running
operations almost like it was an
intelligence based entity running all
thing I don't know that that's the case
it just looks like it is and
um I just don't think the details matter
but the the one that really
puts it in Focus the best is the January
6th stuff if you if you had never heard
any hoaxes being perpetrated against
Trump you might say oh that sounds
reasonable that he was trying to
overthrow the country or something but
as soon as you start asking any
questions about that such as all right
connect the connect the dots let's say
Trump was trying to overthrow the
country and he got some some people to
say that they were the fake electors but
they were the real ones you know let's
say they were claiming they were real
ones
how would that go would everybody else
in the country just say well you got us
we didn't see you doing this fake
collector thing let's just go on you're
the president now of course not it would
go to the Supreme Court like everything
and then we'd probably get some kind of
result we could live with or let's say
that the the protests continued what was
going to happen were the people who
didn't have weapons who were trespassing
in one building was that enough to
conquer the country
well you know give me give me some
details about how trespassing turns into
control of the nuclear Triad and the
fact that half of the public believes
that that was an Insurrection or it
could have been one or that under any
circumstance that could have turned into
something that would have changed the
the leadership of the country by itself
there's no reasonable way that could
have happened but yet half the country
has been convinced they did half the
country believe the fine people hoax
that half the country believes that the
president suggested drinking a
disinfectant none of those things
happened the laptop we know was not
Russian disinformation
Etc so the the January 6 slash
Insurrection quote quote unquote
um it was just an OP not the event but
the way it was treated and the way they
impeached him was just an OP to make
something that was a legitimate protest
meaning people had legitimate complaints
I don't know about the reality of it but
they had legitimate complaints and they
acted out and some some got out of
control and some were violent but when
you see when you see how thoroughly half
of the country has been brainwashed into
thinking that was something you would
call a coup
or an insurrection
when it seems far more obvious that the
way Trump has been treated in you know
before the first election and all the
way through seems like more of an
Insurrection or ongoing coup attempt
against somebody who was elected legally
once and his claim is that maybe he got
elected twice but I'll leave that to
earthquake
foreign